ein familien abenteuer das mit dem tod
endet in der miba wenige minuten nach
dem abflug ist dort eine deutsche
familie mit einem flugzeug abgestürzt
eine vierköpfige familie alle
familienmitglieder sterben bei diesem
crash auch die südafrikanische piloten
das alles passiert in einer cessna 210
die familie hatte das flugzeug
gechartert es dann gegen mittag dort
abgehoben mit diesem kleinen flugzeug so
einem traumurlaub zu einem traumflug
dort im äußersten osten namibias wenige
minuten später nach dem start ist dieser
flieger dann in der nähe eines kleinen
dorfes auf einer insel abgestürzt die
vierköpfige familie tun
[Musik]